- Tell. get it up.
(audience applauding)
They still standing.
Yeah. Wait till that's (indistinct)
from their previous work.
You've seen "First Lady"
it's so good. Anyway.
Did you plan this?
- No, actually, we didn't.
- We didn't it.
- It's a happy coincidence.
- That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- The door opened
- And I was like,
you had to have thought you
were going to a vog photo shoot.
You both were like, did you see the puppy?
Do y'all like puppies?
- I did see.
- I still smell like puppy.
- Yes. It's so cute.
- I feel good.
- It's hard for me to turn away.
- I know. I know.
Not take them home.
- Do you have puppies or cats or anything?
- I'm actually due for a puppy.
- Oh.
but I had--
- Kind of sounded like you
we were gonna have the puppy.
(everyone laughing)
Amazing.
- I used to have a lot of dogs
and then one by one,
they kind of passed away.
And so I don't have
any dogs at the moment.
I do have a cat. Bella
- Okay.
- She's a very special cat.
- Very special cat.
- And she would also go with us.
- Awe, Do you have dogs?
- Yeah, actually.
- She passed away my first and only dog,
her name was LuEllen.
This is a little bit of
her hair in my necklace.
(audience wowed)
Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's creepy and beautiful.
- Still having him with me.
(everyone laughing)
- I love that. I love that
- Trying to LuEllen.
- [Kelly] Aw. People don't
get it. I have kids too.
And I'm telling you, they're
like a part of my family.
- Oh. Totally, totally.
- One of my dog
She is the best.
- One of my dogs that I
thought I was gonna die myself.
- And that's the name
- That's the name.
- Shrine to my dog
- Really literally is a shrine.
- I Love it. It's love. It's love.
Do your kids usually do anything cool
for Mother's Day with you?
Oh no.
(people laughing)
- They call.
- They call. Well hopefully.
(cast laughing)
- They call that's a,
- I get flowers.
- I'm gonna--
- But we've grown up.
- [Kelly] Yeah, okay. But so what?
You're still their mom.
- They're across the country.
- I know. I know.
- I do stuff for my mom.
- I'm gonna have a talk with your kids.
(Michelle laughing)
Wait.
- Do you do anything with your mama?
- We do. it's when we take advantage,
if all we in the same
place, my sister and I,
my mom and sometimes we'll
get dressed up and go out
but then sometimes like,
let's go to In-N-Out
and eat hamburgers in the car, you know?
Like something fun,
- And do paint by numbers.
- Yeah exactly.
- I love it.
- Be cozy and watch like,
some reality show,
- Binge T.V. Watch "Dateline"
Exactly.
(everyone laughing)
- And those are usually the best ones
and what she really actually wants to do.
So we usually do something like that.
- I love it. Cause people always tell me
for birthday parties. They're like,
'Oh, what do you wanna do for birthday?"
And I'm like, I don't wanna
do. I wanna just do nothing.
I think that sounds awesome.
That's a win sometimes
when you're busy a lot.
- Yeah, exactly. You
take advantage of that.
My mom and I, we joke that, after dinner
we'll look at each other and we'll be,
We've to go on some sort of dessert hunt.
So, we'll drive like 30 minutes
to a Dairy Queen or something.
Like random.
(Dakota laughing)
- I can totally fit in your family.
And reminder, if they
don't turn it upside down
before they give it to you, it's free.
- Yeah.
- So the new series.
- I wanna get to it.
'Cause it's incredible.
It's "The First Lady".
And usually it's hard for me.
I'm a single mama. Right.
So it's hard for me to watch
everything all the time.
But I was literally, I was so
glad. I put my kids to bed.
I put it on
and then 2:00 AM hit
(Kelly laughing)
and I couldn't stop watching it.
- Oh.
It was..
I know I was so mad at y'all cause
I wanted to watch it.
'Cause I love watching people's stuff
but I literally could
not stop watching it.
It's so good. Did you know?
'Cause you play Betty Ford,
you play Your Daughter.
But did you know anything really
about other than Betty Ford clinic?
That's what I know.
Everybody kind of knows.
- Right?
- Other than Betty Ford clinic,
I really didn't know that.
And obviously she had
been very open and honest
about her own addiction.
- I love that.
- Which was very taboo at the time.
And what I came to learn about her is.
As if it weren't enough, she
was so much more than that.
She was quite political while she was in.
And especially for a First Lady.
She was running a command
center to get the equal rights
amendment ratified in the White House.
- Yeah.
- She was a pro-choice
Republican First Lady who took
on a feminist agenda.
- Yeah.
- Much to the chagrin of the conservatives
who were in power.
You just couldn't shut her up.
- Yeah. But I love that.
she just spoke her truth.
- She came out and spoke
about her own breast cancer,
which raised awareness
and hundreds of thousands
of women then got screening.
It was the number one killer
of women ages 40 to 45.
And nobody was talking about it.
She talked about mental health,
her own issues with that.
She was so open and honest with people.
She was quite extraordinary.
- And you two would get this.
We all would get this.
It's very hard to be that
vulnerable in the public eye
and be that open in the public eye.
'Cause there's so much scrutiny.
- I would never be that open
in public eye.
(loud laugh)
- I think I would be. But I
think my mama would appreciate,
if I wasn't as open.
I think it is important though.
It's such an important character.
And I feel like, did you
know much about Betty Ford?
I didn't know a ton about her
they play a huge role these First Ladies.
- Totally. They do.
And I think, similar
to what Michelle said.
I knew about the treatment
center in the clinic.
I know people who have
gotten help at at her clinic.
And again, like you said,
if that wasn't enough
she did so much more and
getting to play her daughter,
they were extremely close.
The Ford's only daughter
and their relationship
was. Yeah, look at that.
- Yeah, was so nice.
They are so nice.
- Their relationship was very special.
And Susan was a real confidant for Betty
it was wonderful to get to learn more
about the whole family
but especially Betty.
- And it was so nice
and such a surprise when they cast Dakota
because I was kind of, well into working
and I didn't know that they had cast her.
- Yeah.
And you know.
- I worked with her and she was seven.
- I know, on "I Am Sam".
I was gonna say that.
- It was her first movie.
- She turned seven.
I remember, I think I gave
you a Barbie, like Winnebago.
- Winnebago.
(Dakota laughing)
- And I remember,
I don't know, maybe I got
balloons for your trailer,
but I remember I was sitting
on the floor with you
and Elle. Elle was this big. She was this big.
And so I already had these
sort of mothering instincts,
- How full circle is that moment?
Yeah.
- It was amazing.
Well, I turned 27,
working on this.
- So 20 years later.
- It was literally 20
years to the exact time.
That was my first film. "I am Sam."
And so, it's such a fundamental part of,
kind of who I am.
And Michelle is a part
of all of these memories.
And So.
- She was just a little.
(cast laughing)
- I love the show.
It's so incredible.
- Thank you.
- And seriously y'all
if you're watching it
just make sure you have time.
'Cause you won't want to not.
You'll have to go to the next one.
It's so annoyingly awesome.